the nominees for Best Original Song are
from cry freedom cry freedom music and
lyric by George Benson and Jonas won one
from dirty dancing the time of my life
music by Frankie privets John de Nicola
and Donald Markowitz lyric by Frankie
Trebek from mannequin nothing's gonna
stop us now music and lyric by Albert
Hammond and Diane Warren from Beverly
Hills Cop to shakedown music by harold
faltermeyer and Keith Forsey lyric by
harold faltermeyer Keith Forsey and Bob
Stephen the Princess Bride storybook
love music and lyric by Willy deville
and the winner is the winners are
Frankie privet John de Nicola and Donald
Markowitz strike had the time of my life
from
well about a year and a half ago a
gentleman called me up and told me that
I should write a song for Dirty Dancing
it would change my life so I'd like to
thank Jimmy Einar for changing my life
I'd like to say that this award really
belongs to all the people that were
involved in making a dirty dancing that
includes Eleanor amel bill and Jennifer
for grade 2 wet Patrick and Jennifer for
their performance Kenny Mike and Linda
like to thank Wester own pictures RCA
Records
Burt Bedell and Liz Allan arrow D all my
friends for supporting me the man
upstairs and my parents for the best
duet of all I like to thank the Academy
and like ten Jimmy and Linda Gottlieb I
like to thank my my father Marvin
marquess brand born folks John Philips
herb and Valerie wise and everybody else
take it away Joe
I just like to dedicate this award to my
mom and the people at Deaconess Hospital
who are helping I hope this makes her
feel better thanks a lot Martin Sophie
and Jana glasses
you